- Ooh, that's a question
for me, I have no idea.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- How Korean are you, out of 10?
- I don't know; I feel like
you should answer that for me.
I look very Korean; people
tell me I look very Korean.
- Physical wise, you're like eight,
I would say, eight out of 10 Korean.
Personality wise I think you're five.
- Evan, I think, just look
wise, like you said physical,
I think you look more
American than Korean,
but personality wise six.
- Six?
- Yeah.
- We both fluently speak Korean.
We both speak Korean in our households.
I think we're fairly right in between
the Western culture
and the Korean culture.
(playful music)
We both do not wear make up.
In Korea I notice a lot of guys
actually do wear make up on a daily basis.
Looking pretty is kind of like a trend.
- Cosmetics for men is so
developed in Korea now.
They have, like, something called pact,
so it's like your hands get
messy, they don't want that,
so BB cream, but like in
a little circular tube,
and you just have to open
up and they have a mirror.
They have that cushion thing.
- Interesting, I did not know that, wow.
- They have that specific lines for men.
- Oh, what?
In terms of why Korean guys wear make up,
I think it's more of a culture.
The beauty standard is a
little different from here.
Guys tend to look more prettier,
especially in South Korea.
If you look better, if you're prettier,
you're socially more acceptable,
that's just how it is.
It's messed up, but that's just how it is.
- What ever boosts your
confidence, you know?
It's your life.
- [Evan] Go ahead.
- Yeah, do it.
- You do you.
(hip-hop music)
- It's a mandatory thing for,
two years, around two years.
Even if you live in America
and you are a Korean citizen,
you have to go back,
serve, and then come back.
- That only applies if you
don't have permanent residency.
- If you're a permanent resident,
or you're an American citizen,
then you'd have to enlist.
- It kind of became a culture
thing, where if you don't go
and if you live in Korea, Korean men
kind of just look down on you.
(slow music)
- I like cash.
(laughing)
I like cash.
- As a gift?
- Like a passion item?
- No, I think cash.
- Cash? (laughs)
(upbeat music)
So, I'm a non smoker, I've never smoked
cigarettes in my life.
- I am a heavy smoker, I
mean I'm trying to cut down.
That was one of my New Year's resolutions,
but I completely failed.
I was good for like two days.
I just had cigarettes around the house.
I have an older brother and my dad
and my brother both used to smoke.
I think I just started as a curiosity.
Boys and girls, ladies and
gentlemen, do not smoke.
(laughs)
Nowadays in Korea it's really hard
to smoke out in the
streets because there's
designated spots only for smoking.
If you go outside of the boundary,
if someone catches you,
then you have to pay a fee.
- I think Korea is trying to become more--
- A smoke-free lifestyle.
- Yeah, so that's good.
(uptempo music)
I feel like Koreans, they only go to bars.
Bar and nightlife is such
a big thing in Korea.
Difference between Korean
bars and American bars is
American bars is, people stand.
- Walk around.
- You know what I mean, right?
But Korean bars is like a table service,
so you sit and talk for hours.
- Bars or cafes and coffee shops.
- Cafes.
- And they just sit there and talk.
- Yeah, that's how we hang out.
(playful music)
- [Danny] I wear a mask some times.
- I wear masks when I have to travel
because I don't wanna get sick.
It's just to protect myself.
- On airplanes, too.
- Airplanes is like the
place that you get sick.
Everybody should wear a mask
when you're on an airplane.
Masks is part of fashion too.
- Interesting, huh? (laughs)
- Yeah, it's part of a fashion.
It's covering your mouth,
it's a part of fashion.
- It comes from K-pop, I feel like,
because K-pop idols when
they don't wear make up
and they're going
somewhere, they have masks
to, like, hide their identity.
(delicate music)
Traditional Korean way of saying hello.
- Even if you're same age, you would bow.
- If it's your first time, yeah.
- Yeah, if it's your first time,
and you don't know that person,
it's a complete stranger, you bow.
Even if it's still younger, you bow.
- If I saw Evan for the
first time, for the show,
I'm like, oh.
- I'd be like, I'll bow, and then once we
get to know each other then
we don't have to bow anymore.
- But you do bow to older people.
- Definitely.
- It's like showing respect.
(puzzled music)
- You go with your group of friends,
you go to a drinking place, sit down,
so I tell the waiter to bring us
a bottle of soda to that table.
- It kind of give them a sign.
- Full on give them a sign, then they'll,
of course, look at you, and be like.
(Evan laughs)
Drink together, yeah, should
we go, or do you wanna come?
(laughing)
- Girls do say yes, and they say no, too.
They're like, "We're okay,
we're just here to chill."
They just wanna be friendly.
- They're showing you that
they have an interest in you.
- Yeah, they're just trying to be friends.
They just wanna get to know you.
These are great questions;
I mean thank you guys
for searching us on Google.
- [Danny] Right, thank you Google.
- You googled it, we answered it for you.
- Hopefully we answered couple
of them pretty accurately.
(light music)